لمن يفضلون السفر الى اوروبا هذا الخبر
راح يسعدكم الان فيزا اسهل وارخص لا واسرع
بلا مواعيد ولا طوابير انتظار طويله نعم
بالفعل سيتغير النظام التاشيره الاوروبيه
سيصبح رقميا الى حد كبير ودون الحاجه الى
وضع ملصقات في جواز السفر قانون جديد
اتفقت عليه الدول الاعضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي وكذلك المشرعون الاوروبيون
لطالبي الفيزا وبمجرد اعتماد رسميا ودخوله
حيز التنفيذ سيكون التقدم عبر الانترنت او
ان تقدم طلبك عبر الانترنت بدل من الحضور
للقنصليات او مكاتب خدمات التاشيرات نحن
بانتظار ان يدخل حيز التنفيذ انا مش فاهمه
ليلى هلا اتاخروا الدنيا صارت من من سنين
في عمليات انه يبحثون عن خلفيات هذا الشخص
حتى وتاخذ وقت طبعا
فجوه القصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات وتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات